Nigeria is Africa's Powerhouse
the continent's largest economy
its most populous country
with a cultural influence on the rest of
the world
what happens in Nigeria passed
significant effects across its borders
it's also Africa's largest democracy
but that democracy is at risk mistakes
cannot be higher to reverse the trend of
democratic deterioration and if Africa's
most influential democracy stumbles
the results could be Grim for the entire
continent
but Nigeria has youth on its side
demography will be the game changer
in Nigeria and across Africa young
people are demanding more of their
governments
so what can the politics of Nigeria's
younger generation tell us about the
state of democracy on the continent
and where it might be headed
it's Friday morning and Mustafa is
getting ready for school
he lives in my degree the capital of
Borno State in Northeastern Nigeria
Ibrahim
ibrahamana
um
good morning everyone for most of
mustafa's 14 years this area has been a
hotbed of violence
today life in this corner of my degree
seems calm foreign
but while mustafa's school might look
ordinary appearances can be deceiving
everyone of the 2 000 pupils at this
school has been directly affected by
terrorism
like many of his friends Mustafa was
orphaned by jihadist group Boko Haram
he was nine years old I will never
forget that day that I lost my parents
two strangers came into her house we had
gunshot they have keyboard of my parents
[Music]
Boko Haram isn't the only threat to
Nigerian security
large parts of the country have become
practically Lawless
kidnapping now affects everyone from
wealthy City dwellers to rural school
children
as the government struggles to contain
not just kidnappers but Bandits
insurgents and separatists it's little
wonder that many Nigerians are losing
faith in their politicians even
government is no longer able to provide
security
it's beginning to lose the people who
should protect democracy are no longer
interested in democracy if it cannot
secure their lives and property
when two nearby countries Mali and
Burkina Faso failed to deal with
insurgents they suffered military coups
few expect anything similar to happen in
Nigeria but the causes of its chronic
instability Run Deep
kidnapping is a billionaire industry in
Nigeria it is driven by in many ways the
economic situation of most young people
and the lack of opportunities and lack
of jobs
foreign
youth unemployment has reached 19.6
percent and more than 30 percent of the
population live on less than 1.90 per
day
Nigeria has oil
but it has not brought Prosperity
instead it fuels corruption
many politicians seek office to get rich
and will do almost anything to win
from stirring up ethnic tension to
handing out cash on Election Day the
buying and selling of votes is quite a
common feature of Nigeria's politics if
you think about the short-term gain a
person is receiving in one transaction
and selling their votes compared to say
earning that kind of money over the
course of a month the incentives are
really really strong for an individual
to sell their vote
it's estimated that some 18 of residents
of Nigeria's Northeast were offered
money or a gift for their vote in 2019.
Countrywide that figure Rose to 21
Vault markets are quite common in a
number of African democracies but also
in Latin America and across Asia both
selling corrodes democracy very much
from the inside because at the very
Inception of this relationship between
citizens and the state you have
corruption at the heart of it
I'm Jonathan Rosenthal the Africa editor
The Economist if you'd like to read more
of our Africa coverage why not take out
a subscription to The Economist you'll
receive daily and weekly updates on
global Affairs and you can read us
online and in the app as well as get our
audio Edition
for the very best offers click on the
link below and now back to the phone
Nigeria's current president muhammadu
buhari is 80 years old and he's running
a country with an average age of 18.
the failure of older leaders to curb
corruption has led to simmering
frustrations among young voters but the
erosion of democracy has sparked a fight
back from the country's youth
and leading the charge is Nigeria's
thriving start-up scene
when the shooting of a Young Man by the
special anti-robbery Squad SARS sparked
widespread protests
it was Nigeria's startup leaders who
stepped up to help the campaign being
private sector and beings removed from
kind of the patronage systems that
control our politics Nigeria's Tech
startups have been Central to fueling a
lot of the political activism we've seen
in Nigeria
the analysis for the space company the
goal here is to understand how space
companies are performing temodayo
honoration is MD of space in Africa a
startup that consults with the African
space industry and governments across
the continent I think the end SAS
protest influenced a lot of things we're
seeing that we cannot trust people in
government to make smart decisions for
us
I think a lot of startup played key
rules during the nsas protest uh some
donated money we also had some you know
people working in certain startups
actually uh getting involved in uh some
of the organizations that were providing
support for people that were physically
protesting
the protests ended suddenly when
soldiers opened fire on demonstrators at
leki Tollgate
SARS was disbanded
but many protesters were still Furious
and police violence remains incredibly
High
the protests had shown however that
young Nigerians would continue to demand
to be heard
and in the run-up to the 2023 general
election there has been a surge of young
people registering to vote
the country's electoral commission
registered nearly 10 million new voters
over three quarters of them were under
35 years old
they're reaching a critical mass where
they can translate those numbers into
influence
and some have gone further
[Applause]
aishanyako is 31 years old she was born
and raised in my degree
[Music]
last year she joined the young
progressives a Grassroots party launched
specifically to give a voice to Young
Nigerians
now she is running to be naiduguri's
Council representative at the State
House of Assembly
anyway
[Laughter]
today Aisha is meeting potential voters
at a camp for internally displaced
people where many struggle to find work
Aisha understands their frustrations
trying to make ends meet as a single
mother led to her own political
Awakening
I have not been employed I have been
going off and done to different stages
States I need to go to Abuja I need to
go to kaduna all in the name of sucking
for a job so my own story is part of why
I said let me contest
Aisha is part of a growing Trend in
Nigerian politics young voters are
demanding candidates who will serve
those historically ignored by the
political process what about those women
that are not educated and they have no
way to get source of income I'm running
for this office to end poor
representation
messages like this are hitting home
[Music]
the young people now recognize that they
hire you formidable Lots they could
actually make the change that is needed
to change any of the dominant party or
voting any candidate of their choice
[Music]
[Applause]
in Nigeria's 2023 presidential election
students and first-time voters helped to
fire up the campaign of this man what's
the lack of solution this is what was
that everybody's life
and leaders that understands what the
program is at 61. Peter Obi might seem
an unlikely leader for the young but his
promise to fight corruption and move
Beyond ethnic politics has struck a
chord with the younger generation he
used one the leadership that is
responsive
to the problem of insecurity the money
we need to invest in education
the money we get to invest in health the
money to pull people out of poverty
have been stolen by people but in a
political system where the two main
parties have Deep Pockets Decades of
experience and few Scruples Obi faces an
uphill struggle to win
it's not just in Nigeria where young
people are trying to hold governments to
account
Africa has some of the longest serving
leaders in the world several of whom
have been in power for longer than most
of their people have been alive many
young Africans think their rulers are
out of touch and self-serving in Uganda
protesters recently demanded an end to
corruption
they're not the only ones
Togo went for almost one year long
people actually held protests against
the enyasi great regime
[Music]
protesters in Ghana have called on their
president to step down over
mismanagement of the country's economic
crisis there are so many social
movements it's pair headed by Young
People in West Africa and Africa as a
whole
Dean governments to accounts
come on audience
back in my degree activists like Aisha
are hoping to channel young people's
political Awakening into change at The
Ballot Box
foreign
but there's no guarantee the demands of
the young will be satisfied enthusiasm
could well give way to disillusion young
Africans literally cannot afford to give
up
they are significant barriers to change
in Nigeria the economic hardship that
Nigerians are going through in the last
six years government revenues have been
down insecurity has become increasingly
widespread but on the flip side there
seems to be a sense of urgency
expediency that these issues needs to be
addressed now
there's no opportunity for delaying on
any of these challenges foreign
[Music]
if you'd like to get more of our Africa
coverage click on the link below and
don't forget to subscribe